let's do it let's do this
hi I'm Ryan right I'm Ryan right and
we're both Jerry know is actually is
Jerry and Dan in a video together alone
by ourselves
I'm a little afraid right now I don't
know like this is new changes
brightening yeah I know what you're
saying man at the same time a little
exciting it's a little exciting a little
sexy there's like certain romantic
tension happening you know a sense of
intrigue and danger and you're here yeah
this is basically like every trailer for
every classic movie you've ever seen
where it's like you know adventure
romance isn't read these two never
really actually got along but totally
not true because we get along every time
we're on the show together but everyone
always remarks to me they're always like
you guys are really similar like so
everyone thinks least cuz I've been gone
for a while so yeah thinks that you're
just like Jerry - yeah apparent hey I'm
Jerry - does that mean you're like Dan
like there's like Dan and then you're
like supreme Dan or whatever oh I think
it depends on like what kind of video
we're shooting cause it likes true if
it's a video game based like video yeah
yeah yeah then I am damned - because
that's your forte like that's your thing
and then them right now so I'm Jerry -
here
well no cuz this is video games would if
we were talking about like horror movies
or something than you might skip the
trailer let's talk about the philosophy
of names oh yes and they're qualifiers
yeah oh so what is this we we got to get
down to bidness yeah this is assassins
follow this this may contain content
inappropriate for children so then you'd
be all our parents out there you could
watch it but tell you to let me get the
hell out or at least you could be a cool
parent - yeah some parents are like
listen kiddo not supposed to but hey
you're at home with us have a glass of
wine watch yeah this is Assassin's Creed
game play unity okay what I have which
how many of these they made there's just
there's a lot of freaking trailers I
played Assassin's Creed 2 part way and
then that was like the second or last
video game I I played so well years ago
so okay so there's one two brotherhood
revelations there was a PSP iteration
then there
3 and then 4 black flag and other
annuity so that's like eat wow they bear
a heat there was supposed to be three
two doesn't feel like it was that long
ago no it wasn't these they pump about
like it seems I mean it was cool it
right on running around Renaissance Rome
or whatever learning history cuz I'm
always the weird I was like I want to
read the little history factoids but I
pump them up
alright let's wash your [ __ ] let's check
it as a there's a flying here and it's
gotta be struck a career in this city
men not created equal
for centuries my countrymen surface
under the oppression sandy throughout
and decadent aristocracy the common
people cry out for food for liberty for
justice but they shall have no justice
without someone to fight in their name
I am Java gorgeous I agree it is it
looks fantastic
good work
so I will weigh my silent wall in the
shadows the time has come for revolution
for those to unite and make history
Oh 10 over 50 III Awards holy Sh make
history Assassin's Creed unity pre-order
now for tell bonus offers the guillotine
spindle in-game get a chance to win
prizes every Friday and the explosive
chemical revolution mission 3 order now
available October 28th ok is any game
that involves a guillotine a game you
really want to play depends and just say
what that looks rad I think that's rad I
mean like you said it's a cool time
period to do stuff in a cool place the
only thing that bugs me is that it is
the british-french game a little bit
like what oh yeah hold on
this is all taking place in France but I
have I'm British though for some reason
yeah I don't know I mean it's just
something that you know developers I
don't know if it's a thing like I don't
think anyone's gonna relate with like a
French accent or people even gonna
understand but look at maybe they maybe
they started him out as French and then
they market-tested it and people were
like this french guy well I mean cuz you
could do you could just do a slight
French accent it's very true you can
still understand yeah you don't have to
get the thickest French accent yeah I
don't know it's maybe sometime along the
line with things I don't know I don't
know what the words I'm trying to find
here but yeah just like are we still on
this are we still doing the all foreign
people are British thing yeah
that's basically what's going on but
that's the only complaint that the big
thing that annoys me right now is one of
the ok rant coming up because I had like
before I used to be totally on board
with like pre-order bonuses but now it
really bugs me because they're starting
to put a lot of like advantages to
people that pre-order which is cool like
if you support them you should get a
bonus but like it's getting absurd where
people aren't like developers are not
developing full games because you Eve
you either need DLC or there's
pre-order bonus and this pre-order bonus
is a [ __ ] lottery well it seems I
mean I'm no expert
you know I guess is your forte but like
it seems like it's getting toward the
place work they're not giving away just
like Oh neat little things anymore it's
like hey this could actually come really
in handy if you give us money now
yeah like mm-hmm so that's a little bit
like well some people can't just do this
what the [ __ ] it bugs me I wouldn't mind
if it was like pre-order and you'll be
entered into a drawing but this was
pre-order and the bonus we're giving it
was a game that allows you to be in
contests oh is this I [ __ ] a or go on
maybe it's a guillotine based game where
they just randomly pick someone to
behead oh I don't want a nice life you
got to be sure you want this game it
might not be worth dying of yeah it
might not be worth it like an execution
right but however you know it does come
with a mission too which is cool you
know oh yeah the that's not a need the
chemistry chemistry thing yeah see you
know I rant about all those pre-ordering
stuff but I totally pre ordered destiny
because I wanted the beta well that's
the thing I mean I can see that it's
like oh I can't believe they're doing
this you know because not everybody
can't but but I gotta get it but I got
it like that yeah like I complained
about the trap but I'm all for the trap
every time it's hard you know yeah it is
it's really hard durable mmm no that's
not the right synonym oh now what
subscribe on YouTube I'm not gonna
subscribe it it
speaking of subscribe describing hey
yeah yeah yeah right there subscribe to
the channel you know what to do click
that button that's one port and and dad
Dan you've got channel - we got the
button down here down here if you
haven't heard me say this every time I'm
on your like 600 times you know what to
do press the button yeah cross-promotion
Bing now we both get higher job status
yeah and we all and you got to enjoy
this wonderful journey of Jerry and Dan
and I huh
I hope people enjoy it I mean this is
like that I feel like we should smash a
champagne bottle or something just to
commemorate the good ship Jerry and Dan
in videos together yeah
it's a very inefficiently named ship if
you have a bottle of champagne busted
open yeah
bust a move I'm sure if Ryan were in the
room right now was she certainly is not
he would make a nut busting joke
something yeah you know yeah ha damn it
it's the good what was that is the ghost
of Ryan oh my god
barking spiders and ghosts markings but
whatever whatever I'd whenever my dad
Barbie would say oh must have been a
barking spider all right hey because
people like Ryan you were awesome may I
get a shout out and one more thing sonic
is getting a movie in 2016 it's going to
be live-action CGI hybrid made by Sony
Pictures that sounds very strange
byah but we're gonna tell Ryan that he's
awesome on your behalf dangerous right
yeah Oh Demetri I said I don't remember
the name I told you I'm very good it's
okay baby what's this
alright on a count of three we'll save
Demetrius his name together okay one two
three
Demetrius right that's your shoutout
ooh right with a W so you're not related
to Ryan by blood but yeah we'll see how
that sonic thing goes yeah that's a
strange idea Simon snow Simon snow Simon
snow of five days ago
I wonder Simon snows related to John
snow that's what I was thinking yeah
yeah this is the show I finally cut up
cut up on caught up on dot got it oh
yeah another amazing video so happy was
the success you've been having I've been
ill lately so a shout out would be
[ __ ] amazing well well Simon what's
what's going on man what do you got is
it the cold I hope it is is it the
sniffle ins you got the Black Plague bro
that is going to that I'm like oh I mean
where else can you build with like true
Simon shadow bro from us from us from
Jerry and Dan and from right right and
from right right he would shout you out
if he was here but he's not
to you now he's not right there um
Thomas Ruby no Thomas will be no Thomas
Robina later stabbed up
sounds like you ought to be like a
lawyer like I'm Thomas Ruby no and if
you had hot coffee spilled upon you in
the last 30 days I will fight for your
skin we will get your money yeah I hope
you have a successful law practice that
seems like a lucrative operation if
you're not going to law school you might
want to consider it now so Thomas says
you guys are a hell er bear Claire bear
hello hello bears awesome Claire bear
shout-out please well here you go Thomas
Ruby no shout out shout shout let it all
out these are the things I can do
without come on I'm talking to you come
on hold on use the song for his law
practice oh [ __ ] that is the money that
belongs to you come on we'll fight a
before you come off the new practice ha
ha ha ha ha hey so that's our show
um stare at stick around for Craig
Ferguson uh worldwide pants Network um
yep yeah hi and then tip your waitress
try to try your children and then we do
5 minutes of talking to each other
without the mic on yeah exactly like
credits rolling peas and carrots hmm
handed we're like Sims now huh hey get
your body a little bit do you want 20
more minutes what's going on she's like
if you don't cut it will never stop yeah